that's actually why people get married
you know just so you know because this
is built into marital vows I'm not
leaving ever no matter what it's like
okay well that definitely puts a
boundary around our arguments right
because I can't say every time you
manifest one of your flaws which you're
likely to do just as often as me well
enough of this it's like that's horrible
man if your whole life is well every
time you get out of line I'm out of here
it's like how the hell are you first of
all you're not gonna admit to ever doing
anything wrong
second you're gonna be on your your like
like a scared cat the entire
relationship because well who knows it
could just come to an end at any moment
it's like you know people say well if
you're if the possibility of divorce is
open it makes you free it's like yeah
that's what you want you want to be free
eight really really so you can't predict
anything that's what you're after it's a
vow and it says look I know that you're
trouble me too so we won't leave no
matter what happens well that's a hell
of a vow but that's why it's a vow right
that's why you take it in front of a
bunch of people that's why it's supposed
to be a sacred act it's like what's the
alternative what's the alternative
everything is mutable and changeable at
any moment well go ahead you live live
your life like that and see what you're
like when you're 50 Jesus it's dismal
two or three divorces your family's
fragmented you've got no continuity of
narrative it's and it's not good for the
kids not by any stretch of the
imagination and so it's a form of
voluntary enslavement I suppose but it's
also equivalent to the adoption of a
responsibility and there's more to it
than that if you can't run away then you
can solve your problems because it might
be okay well I'm stuck with you so how
about we fix things because the
alternative is we're going to be in a
boxing match for the next 40 years
that's the alternative so and you think
you're gonna fix problems without
something like that hanging over your
head there isn't a chance you'll just
avoid them because that's what people do
it's really hard to solve problems
especially in a relationship we're
having a fight and I find out
that it's you know because you're you
were abused by your uncle when you were
five or some goddamn thing you know it's
like it's very frequent that that sort
of thing happens you there's the partner
your partner's you know manifesting some
weird anomalous behavior you just can't
make heads or tails of it it doesn't
seem related to what you're doing at all
they don't want to talk about it and so
as soon as you bring it up they get mad
and then you bring it up again they even
get madder and they tell you that you're
not gonna talk about that or they're
gonna leave and so maybe you're really
really persistent because you're kind of
a son of a bitch and then they break
down and cry you know and then they have
this horrible memory that comes flooding
forward that's completely you don't know
what to do with it and then you have to
sort it out
so you think you're gonna do that unless
there's a good reason you have to know
we better start this out or we're gonna
be carrying it around for the next forty
years that maybe is enough motivation so
you'll actually try hard to solve a
problem that's a lot easier to say well
sorry we're not going there but then
good you'll have it every day every day
every goddamn day for the rest of your
life